Neo mus said something really
interesting and it's kind of touchy
subject so just bear with me the way I
tried to paraphrase this he basically
said that death is good the reason he
said that death is good is because it
allows new ideas to come that's what he
said okay I know it's it's a little
harsh but that's what he said so back to
the coffee shop example right now yeah
it's only Bitcoin Fanatics that accept
Bitcoin um at these coffee shops I agree
with you but as this new generation who
really understand digital technology
genz as we become older we approach our
30s our 40s or 50s we are going to be
doing business in Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies right now I actually
pay people in Bitcoin